destiny too has changed significantly
over time from its original launch and
is now going free-to-play due to this
new free-to-play an ala carte expansion
model there has been a lot of confusion
over which version of destiny two
players should purchase in this video
we'll go into detail on what is included
in each version and briefly break down
three main player types new returning
and veterans to figure out which version
of destiny is best suited for you with
the new ala carte model there are no
longer any prerequisites for jumping
into a destiny 2 expansion this means
you don't have to play at hours of old
content just to be able to play what you
actually want to we'll get to some
important details and fine print a bit
later in the video
particularly when we break down what you
get for purchasing shadow keep
specifically but first we'll start with
new light which is the hardest to
explain destiny new light is the name
for the new free-to-play version which
consists of a shocking amount of content
it includes the base red war campaign
that we saw during destiny two's launch
but it also includes both year 1
expansions curse of Osiris and war mine
everything that was in those versions of
the game will be available to you for
free
. which even includes all of the
leviathan raids what is truly wild
though and makes new light the perfect
starting point for both new and
returning casual players is that all of
the destinations are unlocked this means
you can visit destinations that were
released after year 1 and explore places
like the tangled shore dreaming city and
even the moon the reprised and
reinvented location commonly visited in
the original destiny exotics from year 2
will also be available such as the are
bolused bad juju
Thunder Lord an outbreak perfected all
pvp maps will be available and you will
also have access to the free rolling
updated content that will be made
available during the shadow keep season
known as season of the undying this
includes the festering core and the
scarlet keep strikes the new armor 2.0
system combat finishers the seasonal
artifact reprised pvp maps familiar to
d1 veterans and free seasonal rank
rewards which we'll get into later
according to Bungie you'll have access
to gambit a PvE VP mode that was first
introduced in the Forsaken expansion and
its annual pass version gambit prime
black armory forges will be accessible
but whereas the forges are quite frankly
TD
the six-person match made endgame
activity known as the menagerie is an
absolute treat we don't know yet if
those modes will be active immediately
on the game's main director hub as they
usually require some initiation quest
steps you can go to GameSpot comm and
check out our guides to help you get
started
the next version after new light is the
Forsaken complete edition recently
having undergone a price reduction this
version includes all of the content
available in the free to play version
with the addition of the aldryn soft
campaign storyline which follows your
quest for revenge
and honor of an NPC Ally cayde-6 the
most significant piece of content locked
away behind this version of destiny 2
are the new subclasses these are
variations to your Guardian that can
radically change your role in a larger
team and offer different perks and super
abilities that you may find interesting
an impressive number of exclusive
exotics have been released since
forsaken 's launch and not having access
to them may be discouraging for players
who expect to play destiny in the long
term last wish scourge of the past and
crown of sorrow are also exclusive rates
and can only be accessed with ownership
of forsaken the final version of destiny
2 is the standalone DLC shadow keep
shadow keep includes new story missions
and quests a new dungeon to be released
midseason post-launch and an all-new
raid located in the black garden among
other things now I cannot stress this
enough
based on what Bungie has written and
from the language used buying shadow
keeps deluxe editions does not come with
forsaken this means you will only have
the entitlements of destiny new light
and shadow key you will not have access
to the exclusive gear quests and rates
from forsaken and all of your to
purchasing shadow keep will only grant
you its own exotics quests and campaign
and will also come with a season pass
for season of the undying as if it
wasn't confusing enough breaking apart
destiny into these different versions
there are now constant world updates and
content being shipped in seasons season
of the undying has content exclusive to
shadow keep owners such as the vex
Offensive nightmare hunts leviathans
breath and divinity exotic quests as
well as the premium season track
offering rewards in a fortnight or apex
legend seasonal battle paths style as
you level up according to the game's
director Luke Smith returning and new
players will have a baseline power of
750 on all of their armor and weapons
which was previously the
power level before the new season of the
undying veterans have grown used to this
evolving world but new players might be
surprised to realize that expansions and
seasons aren't mutually exclusive with
destiny to the paid expansions cover
content drops targeted towards more
hardcore players that enjoy pursuing
exclusive exotics exploring dungeons and
challenging the endgame rates seasons on
the other hand we'll have some free
content accessible to all players but
we'll still need ownership of the season
pass to fully access all of the upcoming
content this means that if you are a new
player you should probably stick to new
light to see if destiny 2 is right for
you will get a gob stopping amount of
free content including access to much of
what Guardians have been playing for the
last year and forsaken but solid game
looks like gambit menagerie and access
to all the destinations you'll have
every opportunity to take a proper dive
into the world of destiny and see if you
would like more you may find yourself
enviously inspecting another Guardian
with exclusive glowing armor and exotic
weapons but for not needing to pay a
dime it's a superb place to start if you
already know that you are more of a
hardcore player that will enjoy a power
level climb and want access to all the
bounties quests and exotics available
you'll want to consider buying the
expansions returning players who may
have grown jaded from the low point of
year one after the original hype for
destiny - but still consider themselves
to be completionist our hardcore gamers
familiar with the games grind should
consider grabbing forsaken the complete
edition in addition to shadow key the
forsaken campaign is also perfect for
players who want to pick up where they
left off in destiny - the Rays in
particular some of the grandest
locations in the Destiny universe and
for players who want to challenge
themselves experience as much as they
can or want to experience the game
chronologically the Forsaken complete
edition expansion might just be the
perfect missing piece to bridge the gap
between new light and shadow key shadow
key turns a new page in the developers
philosophy and is best for almost every
group of gamer interested in destiny
that would ideally like to play all of
the new content right away the whole
idea of shadow keep is breaking down
barriers and letting you dive right into
the game so if you're a new player that
wants to play the latest content without
anything blocking your path or maybe you
have friends that are on shadow keep and
you want to play at the same pace as
them then it's worth looking into the
same idea applies to returning players
who aren't particularly bothered with
missing out on the endgame content from
forsaken or don't care about trying to
collect all of the exotics for the time
being if you're buying shadow keep the
other consideration is whether or not
you also want to get the season pass
because shadow keep owners don't
to worry about that choice at least for
this season but if you buy forsaken or
you stick to destiny a new light it's
important to remember that the season
pass has its own exclusive content as
detailed earlier and will have to be
purchased separately if you don't own
chat okey so there you have it consider
whether or not you are interested in
destiny to casually or if you are more
of a hardcore gamer and how fast you
want to dive into the new content
definitely stay tuned with GameSpot as
we will consistently be providing a lot
of great articles and videos detailing
high level gameplay weekly zero location
guides cross save explainers and game
guides and more a warm welcome to all
the new Guardians diving in a new light
and a player's new and old alike always
remember the moons haunted